dass ich so was man mache hat also ich
wirklich ich habe jetzt mit maximal 500
euro gerechnet und das ja auch cool
gewesen weil das ist jetzt vierfache
wird gut
ich bin gespannt ich bin wirklich
gespannt was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen beim neuen video ja leute ich
hoffe natürlich euch geht's gut heute
ist schon der vierte tag der alex divis
woche und dialektisch woche nur sich von
der alex die besprochen wird jeden tag
um 19 uhr gibt es ein neues video zu
irgendeinem richtig kein produkt wie zum
beispiel zu diesem hier leute wenn ihr
auch noch nicht von der alex wiebusch
woche mitbekommen habt ihr wirklich was
verpasst also jeden tag ein video um 19
uhr werden zum beispiel gestern diese
massage maschine vorgestern hatten wir
den playstation controller wir hatten
schon eine kettensäge und heute sollte
eigentlich was auch richtig cooles
kommen es gibt nur einen haken an der
ganzen sache wir hatten heute donnerstag
den 13 dezember und wenn man jetzt mal
schaut ich bin euch mal kurz einen
screenshot ein falls sie jetzt mal laden
sollte und zwar das produkt und das ist
eigentlich heute gehen sollte kommt bis
zum 12 12
fast da ist aber noch nicht da und wir
haben heute den 13 12
also irgendwas lief da ein bisschen
schief ich hab natürlich auch schon eine
menge andere sachen bestellt die zum
teil schon da sind allerdings muss ich
eigentlich erst euch dieses produkt
zeigen damit ich weiter machen kann
welche tiere verstehen also das gibt's
da noch hoffentlich ich hoffe es kommt
heute an das gibt's dann hoffentlich
morgen sonst über worden was ich mir für
morgen auch irgendwas anderes einfallen
lassen
das sind so sachen da kann man damit
rechnen ist halt blöd trotzdem habe ich
mir heute was überlegt weil es mich
wirklich mal interessieren hat ich bin
da gestern abend spontan aufgekommen hey
was machst du denn das ding jetzt morgen
nicht passt dann kommt ihr habt sie
wahrscheinlich am titel auch schon
gelesen
trotzdem bevor ich damit jetzt anfange
wollte ich noch auf das gewinnspiel
aufmerksam machen ich habe euch ja
gesagt in jedem video könnt ihr dann das
jeweilige produkt + den 100
gutschein gewinnen das gilt natürlich
auch für heute wir haben ja kein produkt
deswegen haben wir nur den gutschein
also wenn er bock habt mut zu machen
schreibt einfach irgendein kommentar
abonniert main kanal und schon nimmt die
zeit am gewinnspiel
alle gewinner werden am 25 12 bekannt
gegeben
und dass wir jetzt genug gelagert wir
fangen an ja theoretisch ja ich meine
wir da steht to [ __ ]
dann las ich den ja nicht gewinnen also
wirst du sehr klar wenn da steht ich mag
dich nicht ist es noch etwas anderes
versteht ihr dann meinetwegen aber heute
und zwar jetzt wahrscheinlich auch das
ist aber ein schönes bild hier das
gefällt mir das zeug habe ich auch
bestellt das auch noch nicht da obwohl
es expressversand war jetzt
wahrscheinlich am titel schon gelesen es
geht heute um das teuerste produkt auf
ganz frisch ja die seite hat jan sich
seinen ruf das ist alles billiger
schrott vieles davon ist wahrscheinlich
auch billiger schrott allerdings war ich
ja jetzt gestern und vorgestern im video
wirklich positiv überrascht vor allem
video gestern müssen und das massage
dingen gingen das war schon echt cool
und ich hab ich halt gefragt es gibt
eine menge videos darstellen leute das
teuerste produkt auf amazon oder sonst
wo es jetzt allerdings passieren wird
wenn ich sage ich bestelle ist heute ein
video das teuerste produkt obwohl ich
habe keine ahnung und an die die sich
jetzt denken hey das ist doch maximal
100 euro nein ist es garantiert nicht
zum beispiel die kettensäge die ich
vorvorgestern gezeigt habe hat 71 euro
gekostet und ich habe schon eine menge
sachen gesehen zum beispiel auch ein
tablet für 250 euro ob das jetzt das
teuerste ist oder nicht werden wir sehen
was tolleres habe ich bis jetzt noch
nicht gesehen und wir schauen einfach
mal nach ich bin gespannt und ich würde
sagen die suche kann losgehen das wird
sicherlich einige zeit dauern bis ich
sagen kann ok was teures finde ich jetzt
nicht aber wir werden sehen also wir
hatten hier schon mal ein notebook für
209 euro geht ja direkt schon mal ganz
gut los ist mal ein bisschen runter ein
messer für 176 euro
da fragt man sich immer wieder zustande
kommen man kann hier auf der einen seite
messer 476 euro bestellen ich kann euch
versichern dass wird sicherlich auch
noch irgendwo für 20 geben
wir haben ein messer gefunden für 203 3
die gute stimmung für sich schon bei 233
euro mal schauen ob wir das noch
überbieten können
ich schaue mal nach einem smartphone für
wollte ich brauchst du nicht weißt nie
was muss das können das iphone xs oder
ist ja ein richtig gutes ahnen
da kann ich dir eigentlich hier nur das
mobile vorn er elf ans herz legen um
fünf euro das auch gut expands ist busch
items band 100 dollar
warum also wir sind gerade nur auf der
suche nach über 233 euro
scheiße leute leute leute das habe ich
jetzt nicht gedacht als ich habe euch ja
eben gesagt der teuerste also leute ich
hab gerade diesen lapdock er gefunden
für 337 euro der auf anscheinend schon
bestellt wurde
computer straight into bayern also hier
bin ich auf jeden fall schon mal einer
guten kategorie wir sind jetzt hier
schon bei 337 euro der kostet sogar 300
51 euro also ich muss sagen ich hab
gedacht bis 500 euro komme ich
vielleicht darüber auf keinen fall an
sich habe ich natürlich auch vor dass
dann zu bestellen und einmal
auszuprobieren dann vermutlich wieder
zurück zu schicken weil ich hab
eigentlich genug laptops was ist das
bitte
die marke habe ich noch nie gesehen und
es hat auch noch niemand bestellt
wir haben hier ein notebook für 1000 170
euro und wenn ich mir gerade die daten
ja angucke dann ist es eigentlich totale
abzocke also ich glaube das sollte man
auf keinen fall für das geld kaufen
wir kopieren das mal kurz ich schon mal
kurz wie teuer das sonst ist ein
chinesischer hersteller oder japanisch
eins von beiden das hier ist
wahrscheinlich sogar noch neueres modell
als das und man spart sogar 25 euro
würde ich natürlich niemals kaufen ich
klicke das jetzt hier trotzdem mal an
erster stelle jetzt ist die frage nach
was sucht man das noch teurer ist weil
das problem dass man kann auch auto da
willst du irgendwelche gadgets für geben
kann man darüber ein auto bestellt wie
soll das denn hier ankommt leute ich
pausiere das ganze hier mal kurz und
suchen noch ein bisschen weiter und dann
melde ich mich gleich und ich hoffe ich
finde auch irgendwann
leute ein kurzes update das ding ist ich
sehe es eigentlich überhaupt nicht
einmal jetzt einen laptop zu bestellen
weil das finde ich nicht gut
deswegen suche ich irgendwas was mich
halt noch mehr ansprüche das hat dann
auch spaß macht beim auspacken nur das
ist so schwer also meistens jetzt halt
ihr sieben euro also ich habe immer noch
nicht gefunden ich habe mal gegoogelt
und ich bin auf dieses video besteht
über den bin ich damals überhaupt auf
wunsch gekommen um ehrlich zu sein
und die haben hier im video ein relax
full body shiatsu massage für 2249
dollar das problem ist also ich dachte
geil schaue ich mir mal an das problem
ist ich hab mal ein massage
hier ist überall wieder nur irgendwie so
ein ding was ich gestern schon probiert
hat aber seinen ganzen stuhl findet man
halt nicht das teuerste war irgendwie
für 250 euro ebenso was ich habe ihn was
ist das spa pediküre cher für füße
also sowas ja noch nie gesehen
sowas hat allerdings anscheinend auch
kaum jemand vorher gekauft und es gibt
ein paar rezensionen verkauf von nuon
chea
ja komm ich habe mir noch einen stuhl
für den find ich aber herzlich den auch
wieder herrlich das wovon wirklich sagen
die paketboten die kommen so oft zu mir
und ich stelle mir gerade vor der eine
mussten wir so einen riesen studie
ankommt den habe ich ja gar nicht
gesehen er ist noch teurer
man man man 209 euro war am anfang
danach kam 233 euro dann kam 732 euro
dann kam 337 euro dann kam 1170 euro
dann habe ich den hier gefunden 4842
euro und der herbst nicht einfach ja gut
er sieht auch noch ein bisschen
hochwertige aus 2000 euro für ein stuhl
wo ich meine vier cent was er tun kann
okay leute ich mache das jetzt über
paypal
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dass ich so was man mache halt also ich
wirklich ich habe jetzt schon maximal
500 euro gerechnet und das ja auch cool
gewesen weil möglich zu sein wenn man
zum beispiel zwei videos zu dem thema
macht hat man dann diese 500 euro
meistens wieder raus das ist vierfache
wird gut
ich bin gespannt ich bin wirklich
gespannt ich würde sagen mehr sagt zum
thema gar nicht wir sehen uns dann
wieder morgen wahrscheinlich nehmen gern
am gewinnspiel teil schreiben kommentar
abonnieren
und das war es formiert hotline zschau
[Musik]